magalie vaé elle a gagné 1 million
d'euros non imposables à la fois savoir
que c'est ce que sa mère possible
alors vous avoir fait que c'est une
avance sur les disques sur les banques
c'est à dire que tu as un million et tu
dois vendre des disques jusqu'à ce que
ça leur rapporte à millions 6 et plus tu
touches en plus si c'est moi bah tu
gagnes quand même l'argent estime que
les ventes ont pas été très bonne mais
tu as gagné ton millions d'euros c'est
ça et quand on a fait le doc sur toi oui
si j'étais halluciné donc tu vis dans
une petit on peut dire où tu vis oui je
suis dans le loir et cher voilà même ma
famille aussi
et ton millions tu m'as dit gelé
totalement perdu comment tu as perdu ce
million j'avais 18 ans oui déjà
et puis voilà on fait des mauvais choix
on rencontre aussi de mauvaises
personnes et selon la démarche non bah
ça soit dans le métier ou dans la vie
privée ou alors on pense avoir des
garçons qui tourne et je sais quoi ya
des garçons et que son compère
actuellement des relations c'est pas
forcément des copains c'est voilà des
amis ou qu'on pense on pense des années
mais qui te disent quoi par exemple
comment on perd un million pardon non
mais alors ça c'est pas tout
ça c'est quoi on avait placé c'est quoi
un mauvais conseils pendant qu'est ce
qu'on est mauvais conseils bah voilà
déjà dix huit ans on pense que 1 million
oui on a le temps ouais même à 47 avoir
beaucoup plus vite qu'on ne le pense et
surtout voilà quand bas on se rend pas
compte moi j'avais jamais payé d'impôts
de ma vie je ne savais pas combien on
allume prélever quel est le plus mauvais
qu'on ce qu'est le plus mes placements
comptait faire à ce que les gens des des
vautours qui survit autour de toi qui es
tu on ose alors c'est surtout les faux
amis d'accord voilà j'avais il ya une
époque où j'avais un groupe d'amis
autour de moi que je pensais mes amis
donc j'ai voulu leur faire plaisir je
pensais vraiment que le tout frais qu un
jour une voiture pas du tout je leur
payer les soirées on prenait le taxi je
pouvais pas leur payer des vacances
voilà et et puis intégrateurs quoi les
grimpeurs voilà et puis bah le jour où
il n'y a plus rien bagad du père et du
coup tu études et acheter une maison un
truc tu vivais dans un dans un danger
terme en location mais dans un très bel
appartement oui enfin j'étais dans un
appartement j'ai jamais été bling bling
tout ça c'est pas en plus j'avais pas le
permis n'ont pas de voiture mais ces
voix là
on sait qu'on pense se faire plaisir on
pense qu'on a le temps et puis bah je
l'avais aussi moment on pense que il va
y avoir d'autres galas d'autres machins
et est aujourd'hui ce que justement on a
je ne sais pas si après ce qu'on a cet
extrait où elle négocie pas du haut
plateau a négocié non on l'a pas je sais
qui est un extrait où on te voit c'est
très gentil aujourd'hui tu chantes
encore notamment dans des mariages alors
à part dont d'anciennes ceux ci étaient
délicieux d'animation c'est différent
j'ai une société d'animation donc quand
vous étiez venu en effet ça venait de se
créer ça fait maintenant trois ans donc
la société voilà à évoluer voilà les
clients sont contents donc voila c est
ce qu a pas là c'est qu'il y ait cet
extrait tu nous a laissé filmer schultz
a notamment magnifique de ta part et
donc les personnes qui vont se marier
disent bon bah voilà nous on aimerait
avoir magalie vaé pour chanter tu dis
très bien combien de temps deux heures
et donc tu signé un contrat avec eux et
tu leur dis voilà deux heures magalie
vaé si un extra c'est 50 euros mais deux
heures magalie vaé pour chanter à votre
mariage c'était je crois 250 euros
c'était 400 500 tout 400 cantons a fait
les zénith quand on gagne un million
d'euros allait chanter pour 250 ou 300
euros pendant deux heures dans un
mariage et la chance comme moi comment
on vit quand même
je suis chanteuse oui je suis pas
chanteuse de zenit non un chanteur c'est
part réservée au zénith ce n'est pas
réservé aux grandes salles non vous
savez combien il ya de chant temps en
temps mais tu ta de cotco code pour
défier quand tu chantes est au zénith
après la star ac avec une gamine c'est
ce que tu te disais dans dix ans
j'entrais pour de samba dans un mariage
je pensais même pas gagné à la base
aujourd'hui j'ai la chance d'en faire
encore mon métier qu'elle conçoit la
taille je suis pas là je suis pas là
pour chanter dans des zénith h 24 non
mais c'est très beau s'est à son tour
doc est magnifique qu'est ce qui veut
dire quelque chose d'allergie l'enquêté
serait aussi compliqué c'est que qu'on
atteigne star dans un domaine comme la
chanson acteur x tard il n'y a pas
beaucoup de reconversion possible parce
qu'on voit pas tout d'un coup est tracté
à toi coude devenir agent immobilier ou
travailler chez darty etc donc on est
condamnés appelés à rester chez soi à
temps que le téléphone sonne il sonne
pas on a un train de vie il faut payer
le plein de choses que ça donc ça part
très vite tout ça donc c'est un monde
qui s'écroule très rapidement mais
est-ce que vous parlez de tours un
instant non
c'était pmp tous les soirs avec un très
beau salaire qui était très mérité tout
d'un coup tu fais moins de tpm paix tu
fais un petit ça c'est ton salaire à
diviser par deux ou par trois qu'est ce
que tu peux faire effectivement tu vas
pas de serveur tu vas pas être un
embarras heureusement que tu mon emploi
un peu tu me fais un peu travail extra
mais j'ai beaucoup moins haut j'ai la
chance de ne pas avoir bu beaucoup de
besoins avec moi il me faut quelques
potes un verre de vin rouge un peu de
nous amuser jeunesse comme ça donc j'ai
pas de besoin de belles voitures de
d'appartements je suis locataire de
quelque chose je n'ai pas de maison la
campagne j'ai rien du tout et voilà donc
je vis chichement mais ça me suffit je
me plains pas du tout on gagne très bien
ma vie et voilà est-ce que j'ai je le
dépense et voilà je le met pas de côté
c'est dommage mais j'ai un esprit comme
ça à peu fournis et et oui juste 20 ans
et hugo hugo tulle forcément pardon mais
c'est normal tutu vit dans l'opulence
aujourd'hui ça te fait peur parfois de
deux pays avaient déjà j'oublie jamais
d'où je viens moi je viens de clichy
sous bois dans le 93
enfin voilà et puis c'est sûr que ma vie
a un peu changé depuis quatre ans bien
évidemment mais alors ça va paraître si
on m'a peut-être risible mais en tout
cas moi je suis pas quelqu'un de
matérialiste donc en fait vivent dans un
grand appartement ou un appartement de
modeste ça me ça ne pose pas de problème
j'aime voyager mais je voyageais déjà
avant j'ai toujours travaillé donc j'ai
toujours essayé de gagner ma vie donc
voilà je pense que faut s'adapter c'est
à dire que pour moi rien et pérenne à un
moment où les choses peuvent changer les
choses peuvent s'arrêter totalement
raison près par les on dit et après
c'est ce qu'on vit et voilà oui non mais
le bonheur doit pas tenir à ça oui moi
j'ai envie de poser une question à
magali que j'adore la dernière que j'ai
beaucoup suivi à l'époque et j'étais
journaliste déjà à l'époque qui se
disaient deux choses la première c'est
que peut-être qu'en comparaison au
précédent vainqueur de la star ac vous
aviez pas été assez soutenue par tf1 et
par la maison de disques chose qui se
dit aussi c'est que les médias à
l'époque ne vous ont pas autant soutenu
alors vous n'avez pas fait autant de
couverture de télé 7 jours de télé star
voilà ma question c'est ça est ce que
vous l'avez ressenti est ce que vous
pensez que finalement séparé meneur
d'hommes
et bien sûr tous
parce la grossophobie bien sûr que j'en
ai j'en ai été témoin et je l' ai vécu
de plein fouet après voilà j'ai envie de
dire que matt ce qui s'est passé il ya
16 ans maintenant ça me passe vraiment
au dessus je suis toujours chanteuse je
fais des galas des concerts à travers la
france j'ai cette chance de vivre encore
de ce métier maintenant je suis devenu
aussi comédienne j'ai un film voilà qui
sort en salles bientôt aulas au mois de
mars à partir du duo à la voilà où fait
à vous sortez un album d'audio alors je
fais partie d'un album de joe voix la
voix sur côté donc de frédéric françois
c'est ça
j'avais avec lui ça a été vraiment je
suis vraiment ravi donc un film voilà
qui sort le 11 marque s'appelle nous ne
m'oublie pas très bien voilà qui aborde
la maladie d'alzheimer précoce bah c'est
parfait et en tout cas vous avez retrait
j'étais très ami avec une chanteuse qui
sape et rika zaraï et qui a un jour m'a
dit une phrase est écoutée l'alien
pascal importante pour tous quels que
soient vos revenus pas de possession pas
de pertes pas de perte pas de souffrance
eh ben c'est très bon
[Applaudissements]